the provocation I want to put to you the
idea that we're going to explore with
the help of this is that all rational
numbers rational numbers what a rational
numbers there forward proceed what makes
a number rational or irrational rational
yeah I heard some ideas there that it's
sort of floating around I so we have the
idea that numbers can be on the number
line but there are some numbers that are
not rational
like hey this guy and you can put him on
the number line you can't put him very
precisely but he's there between between
3 & 4 like a little something more
specific has to do with the start of
this word what is rational really mean
yeah so it means you could write number
as a fraction or as a ratio right for a
very long time mathematician thought
that the only kinds of numbers that
existed were numbers that could be
written as a fraction that were rational
which is why they said well if there's a
number that you can't write as a
fraction then that number is that
procreating the idea like that doesn't
make any sense I can't give such a
number this is this is predating a good
understanding of what this number was
for a long time people thought this was
like some fraction we just didn't know
what it was so people thought
mathematicians for for a long time
that's not to be able to like as if you
can't write a number as a fraction and
so that's why in our human in our
English language this word literally
means like when you call someone
rational what does that mean you're
saying they're crazy illogical that they
don't make sense and that's sort of a
carryover from back in the time when we
didn't think that irrational numbers
made sense but we do now now rational
numbers I heard the number the word
decimals turn around before have you
ever noticed that rational numbers every
single rational number falls into one of
two categories when it comes to decimals
right if you write on rational number in
in decimal form you'll get two different
kinds of decimals do you know what they
are
yeah we recognize you oh he gets it in
one how much have you prepared today
terminating terminating and recurring
maybe your mind didn't go there straight
away because you learnt these a long
time ago right a terminating decimal I
give you an example of a terminate this
or any-any terminating decimals you like
come in when there was anything sorry I
say it again I missed the five point one
sure that's fine
okay give me another one just for the
sake of it giving up can be real
interesting Wow Wow I deserved that
I suppose okay sure fine all right so
these are decimals and they stop they
stop right and it wouldn't take too much
work to work out what the fractions for
each of those were so far so good but we
also know that not all decimals not all
rational numbers that you've added
decimals stop some going on and on and
on forever return so give me an example
of a recurring decimal yes of course I
five point one repeat up I put one on
one on one and don't don't tell me I
will give you the next one five point
one two one two one two one two okay why
did you with your obsession with anyway
it so both of these can also be written
as fractions just for the sake of it
what is a five point one repeater what
is it as a fraction how would you write
it I'll give you a tip it starts with a
five what's the fraction part point one
one one one one one moment what's the
fraction it gives you that human is back
from you seven
yeah Oh 51 over 100 would give you this
right now 51 over 10 will give you this
but 51 over 100 and this is interesting
this is actually a really important
point it gives you a terminating decimal
I'm looking for this recurring one I
wonder if you remember you can confirm
this to the calculator if you like it's
five and nine whereas this guy would be
five and twelve over 99 which we could
write as what we read that as common
factor of how you rub up brains that not
awake yet let's try again common factor
of three between these here right Marie
Nicolas goes it so that makes it 433
okay sorry I've gotta sleep get a laptop
out too
okay now two main decimals they're
carrying decimals but my question is
what makes a fraction one or the other
is there like some kind of pattern to
this now we're mathematicians so we know
there has to be a pattern somewhere
under there even if it's a little bit
hard to find and that's what this is
going to help us with okay so you got
your spreadsheet there we're going to
put some things on this spreadsheet okay
data later never fog grab a seat oh yeah
okay so in your spreadsheet and I'm
going to like you can see I think that's
fine in the top left hand corner I'm
just going to say let's call this column
the left-hand column let's call it
whoops sorry let's call it n for a
number okay so I'm going to fill in this
first column with numbers now
spreadsheets are really cool every cell
in a spreadsheet is its own little
calculator at least if you set it up to
be there okay
so what I'm going to do is run and write
the numbers that I want I'm going to get
the spreadsheet to create the numbers
that I want so the first number I want
is just 1
that's the only number I actually need
to type the spreadsheets going to
calculate the rest of the time this for
me I just want the natural numbers for
counting numbers 1 2 3 4 5 etc I could
type 1 2 3 4 5 etc but I don't need to
to get to 2 I'm just going to say it now
watch carefully it's a bit small sorry
that it's some resolutions to higher but
whatever I'm going to type equals that's
going to tell my spreadsheet hey don't
just thumb or you can see it up there a
bit clearer don't just accept this
number actually do a calculation that
I'm about to tell you okay now I want
the next I'm going to be 2 which is just
the previous number plus 1 right and
then I want this to be 3 which is the
previous number plus 1 so to write the
previous number I'm literally going to
click on or select the previous number
now
when you you can move your mouse or you
know touch your screen or whatever when
you hit that cell up there right it
gives you this what is this name just
stand for what's the a stand for the a
stands for burqa what are those got to
get fed to the column the 2 stands for
the road right and you should find even
if you're using Excel I'm not I'm using
Google sheets you should find that
naming convention is similar okay so a 2
it highlights it in color as well to
indicate to you hey I recognize you're
not just saying random letters and
numbers you're actually referring to a
place a cell within this spreadsheet
what I want to do I wanted the previous
number plus 1 plus 1 okay so I'm going
to go ahead I'm going to equals and
you're like wow my phone it can add one
person one good idea spreadsheet ok now
that part was decidedly more work than
just typing too wasn't it you're like
wow that was a really inefficient way to
just say two but the reason why we did
that is so that we can save space and
time for the next things come back to
this cell that we just created right
what we're going to do is
like that if you on your on your
computers if you've got a an actual
proper computer rather than me which I
with a tablet just right-click on the
cell right click on this cell and you
should get your own menu I know it won't
look like my one but you should have the
option for copy there right if you got
to copy if you right-click on there so
I'm going to copy that cell now here's
the cool thing what I've copied is not
the value I haven't copied the value
I've copied the formula that created
that value I've copied the go to look at
that cell and add one that's what I've
really copied so now if you highlight a
bunch of cells as many as you like go
down like I'm going to go down a [ __ ]
I go let's see I'm gonna go down maybe
well that was more than I want to but
that's okay I'm going to go down like 50
rows ok so I've highlighted that you can
highlight of that with your computer as
well and windows highlight it if you
right-click on your highlighted
selection and now go ahead and paste
because what you're pasting is the
formula right the instructions not the
actual numbers you're not going to get a
whole bunch of two's you're going to get
what it looks at the previous cell and
adds one and looks at the previous cell
and adds one ok so I've got all these
numbers that's great and for number now
what am I trying to investigate I'm
trying to investigate rational numbers
and patterns in whether the decimals are
terminating or recurring okay now this
is just an easy way to generate some
fractions if these are all the counting
numbers right then I can work out
fractions associated with them by saying
let's have another column and let's make
it one
whoops sorry one divided by whatever
that number was